staying in Washington the Senate failing
to move forward with its nearly two
trillion dollar phase three coronavirus
bill after Democrats blocked that plan
they are pushing back on several fronts
and another attempt to push the bill
forward could happen as early as noon
Eastern today now Republican Senator
Bill Cassidy was sounding off on this
program he interviewed didn't interview
with Sandra and he says this is
unnecessary political drama a bill will
pass I think what's required now is for
Democrats to be honest let's hope
Democrats kind of come to the table in
good faith as opposed to hiding their
cards and recognize that whatever
short-term gain they're trying to
achieve it's not worth it
our chief congressional correspondent
Mike Emanuel is live on Capitol Hill
where all the action is good morning
Mike good morning to you much of the
conversation right now is basically
trying to hammer out a deal with the
expectation there could be a series of
votes in about two hours the debate the
discussion right now is between Treasury
Secretary Stephen minuchin and Senate
Democratic leader Chuck Schumer they met
six times yesterday minuchin says the
stimulus package is roughly two trillion
dollars now and responded to criticism
that 500 billion dollars of it is a
slush fund it's a mechanism that we can
use working with the Federal Reserve
that will provide another four trillion
dollars of potential liquidity into the
market that's on top of the Fed's
balance sheet this is a massive
liquidity program that the president is
determined that we're going to support
hardworking Americans yes
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
and his allies are accusing Schumer and
other Democrats of seeking to include an
ideological wishlist
that has nothing to do with coronavirus
McConnell vented his frustration our
nation cannot afford the game of chicken
we can't afford the cynical partisanship
and unconscionable statement to view
this as a partisan opportunity this is
mr. president a national emergency not a
partisan opportunity adding to the
stress from McConnell's the fact five of
his members are out of action
now Senator Rand Paul has tested
positive for coronavirus and senators
Mike Lee Mitt Romney Rick Scott and Cory
Gardner are all in self quarantine after
close interaction with Senator Paul or
others so far there's no sign Democrats
our budget our caucus is united in
trying to deliver a bill that addresses
this health and economic crisis quickly
and we're committed to working in a
bipartisan way to get it done both sides
of the aisle voting for a bill so
there's some health pressure there's
also financial market pressure as we all
do a little social distancing here on
Capitol Hill
Edie so Mike you were disregard it right
that Chuck Schumer the Democratic leader
met with the Treasury secretary about
six times yesterday countless phone
calls I'm sure between the Treasury
secretary and different various
Democrats over the last three four days
how can you ever kratts now claimed that
they were left out of the process when
it's been on record and they were on
tape over the weekend saying they were
working together well and a lot of
frustration is that the senators felt
like they were getting very very close
to a deal and all of a sudden Speaker
Nancy Pelosi came in from California
after being out of the mix for a week or
so and so there's a great deal of
frustration feeling like there was some
trust-building between both parties and
also the administration trying to get
close to finalizing a deal you may
recall in the previous deal you had
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
staying out of it saying let Speaker
Pelosi and the administration hammer out
a deal when they do will pass it in the
Senate
in this case Pelosi got back on a plane
came back and they feel like she's
throwing in things now at the 11th hour
that have nothing to do with coronavirus
all right we'll get back to you live
Mike in the program as this continues
plan